hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and one of the
best and most consequential mysteries in
one piece are the devil fruits and how
these incredibly powerful objects came
to exist in the first place devil fruits
were always a big deal in the one piece
story but they became even more
important with the shocking reveal about
the true nature of luffy's devil fruit
you better believe that devil fruits and
their secret origins are going to be
incredibly relevant in the final saga of
the story so in this video i'm going to
break down the best theories for how the
devil fruits came to be
including my own theory that involves
that ancient civilization on the moon i
even got some help from fellow youtuber
marshall d preach so let's get into it
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
one piece content and you want us to
keep it coming leave a quick like and
comment it only takes you a second but
it helps me out a lot and of course
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell it's a completely free
but very real way of directly supporting
the channel finally this video will of
course contain one piece manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay so first up let's talk
about what is probably the simplest
theory this is the theory that devil
fruits just grow on special trees in the
world of one piece such as the sunlight
tree eve the treasure tree atom the tree
of knowledge on o'hara or the igracial
tree on elbaf after all since a lot of
fruit does grow on trees maybe special
fruit the devil fruit grows on one of
these special trees what really gives
credibility to this theory in my mind
are the blatant references that oda is
clearly making to the garden of eden
from the bible the names adam and eve
come from the biblical story about the
first man and the first woman who were
banished from the garden of eden after
disobeying god and eating a forbidden
fruit from the tree of knowledge of good
and evil to complete the bible
comparison the garden of eden is said to
have been also home to another special
tree the tree of life which is another
name for igdacil in a norse mythology so
we have adam eve the tree of knowledge
and the tree of life in the book of
genesis god creates an idyllic and
abundant existence for adam and eve
inside the garden of eden and there are
many trees there from which they can eat
freely to their hearts content but god
forbids them from eating the fruits that
grow on the tree of knowledge of good
and evil adam and eve respect this rule
initially but one day a serpent tricks
eve by telling her that if she and adam
eat from the tree of knowledge of good
and evil the two of them will become
like gods wanting the knowledge and
power that comes from being like a god
eve eats the forbidden fruit from the
tree of knowledge of good and evil and
she also convinces adam to eat some in
that moment adam and eve suddenly become
aware of their nakedness they discovered
the sensation of shame for the first
time when god appears before them the
two of them attempt to hide their
nakedness with makeshift clothing god
realizes what has happened he curses the
serpent eve and adam and he expels them
from the garden of eden the serpent in
this story is often associated with the
devil although the serpent being the
devil is not actually confirmed it is
only one interpretation furthermore in
the west the forbidden fruit is almost
always portrayed as an apple but we
don't know what kind of fruit it
actually was with all of that said it
becomes clear that the concept of devil
fruits was inspired by the idea of the
forbidden fruit from the bible which
according to some interpretations
involved the devil taking the form of a
serpent in order to convince adam and
eve to eat the fruit like the forbidden
fruit the devil fruits in one piece give
special powers to those who consume them
but there is also a major downside just
like adam and eve were punished for
eating the forbidden fruit those who eat
the devil fruits become cursed and they
can never swim again so because oda is
clearly referencing the bible in regards
to all of these special trees and also
with the parallels between the devil
fruit and the forbidden fruit in the
bible the theory is that devil fruits
simply grow on these special trees or at
least on one of these trees there are
even some people who believe that devil
fruits are created through some sort of
cross-pollination between the adam and
eve tree personally i'm not an expert on
botany but i wouldn't be surprised if
one or more of these trees turned out to
be the origins of devil fruits that said
if you do want more botany related
content here on the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that bell now i'll
turn it over to marshall d preach for
the next theory so first of all thanks
for having me it's truly a pleasure to
be here now is it possible that devil
fruits are actually created from human
sacrifices when asking the questions
what are devil fruits and where do they
come from the best place to look for
answers would be the mad man dr vega
punk himself it's still a mystery but
he's somehow figured out how to combine
the zozo elephant fruit with a sword and
the ino inu-dashan fruit with the
bazooka to create a mobile explosive
turret now what if i told you that the
secret to creating devil fruits is
through human or animal sacrifices or
more specifically a zone being combined
with his soul with the recent
information coming from chapter 1044
about zones having whales it makes you
wonder why were zones specifically
singled out these wills seem to have
some sort of consciousness to the point
where the government states that luffy's
devil fruit was intentionally evading
them and that also makes you wonder if
nika actually chose luffy to wield his
power similar to how a weapon like enema
presents himself in front of zoro as a
challenge another reason to think that
souls may be inside devil fruits is due
to the correlation between a devil fruit
user's nature being influenced by the
traits of the fruit for example luffy
smiling as joy boy carnivorous zones
being bloodthirsty and even non-zoned
devil fruits like ase being a hothead
and so now the question becomes is that
the devil fruit simply choose a user
that matches that personality of the
devil fruit a person with similar
ambitions and will and then enhances
those established personality traits to
the extreme or are the devil fruit users
personalities being influenced by the
fruit itself there was a comment made by
cb0 in chapter 1007 where they
reinforced the idea that momonosuke's
double fruit is a failure but this
doesn't exactly seem to add up because
first of all how would vegapunk know if
it was a failure you would have to eat
it to test it the other contradiction
with this is that yamato explains how
kaido and mominosuki's power works
exactly the same and now we have seen
them both use the flame clouds and the
thing is i don't think vegapunk was
simply disappointed because he prefers
blue to pink so what if i told you that
the real reason why the pink dragon was
a failure was because while vegapunk did
actually manage to extract the lineage
factor from kaido what he was lacking
was the soul trapped inside kato's devil
fruit a sacrifice of a godly dragon in
the past whose soul may have been
trapped inside for multiple centuries
maybe vegapunk can actually feel the
presence lacking compared to the other
true zones that he had encountered in
the past a wheel or soul that all zones
contained if you think about it we've
only seen enameled objects fuse with
their zones and maybe the reason for
this is that vegapunk found out that a
will or soul could bring these weapons
to light similar to how big mom and soul
powers create homies the personality and
life sparked in front free the elephant
sword comes from this trapped whale or a
sacrificed elephant in the past and it
also makes sense when you consider that
the human sacrifices may have been
involved to create the human human
fruits like nika buddha choppers fruit
and onimaru finally when we look at
devil fruits they are powers that
respawn into existence this could hint
at some kind of soul being transferred
to the nearest fruit or at the very
least a form of endless energy cycle
that cannot be destroyed and since only
one bite is necessary to gain the powers
it makes me think once again that the
actual fruit is only a container for
this soul or energy source these human
or animal sacrifices might specifically
only answer how zoned devil fruits exist
but at least it's a start to the mystery
it's possible that zones retain the
personality of the soul and have a
stronger will due to the manifestation
of the original soul's physical body
being a part of the zone thanks preach
and everyone definitely check out
marshall d preacher's channel link in
the description now somewhat related to
the idea that devil fruits could have
been created from human and animal
sacrifices is the theory that devil
fruits contain actual devils inside of
them this theory states that there once
existed a race of devils in the world of
one piece but they became extinct much
like the lunarians were a race of
so-called gods who also became virtually
extinct according to this theory each
devil fruit does contain a soul but it
is not the soul of a human or animal but
rather the soul of a devil which was
somehow trapped or sealed inside the
fruit this would explain the
supernatural powers of the fruits
because this race of devils may have had
supernatural abilities and it would also
explain the fact that devil fruits have
a will of their own because that will
comes from the devils that are trapped
inside of it this means that each devil
fruit user has a devil living inside of
him kind of like the devil possessed in
black clover or the jinchuriki in naruto
this race of devils may have played an
important role in the ancient war and
the void century and so the truth about
them and the origins of the devil fruits
will only be revealed once the story
reaches its finale that's because if we
had gotten this information earlier it
would reveal all the mysteries that oda
wants to keep from us until the very end
so that is why the origins of the devil
fruit still hasn't been explained once
it is explained we will know everything
about the ancient war the void century
and the secret history of the world this
theory would also explain why dr
vegapunk felt that momo's artificial
devil fruit was a failure he knows that
he cannot replicate the soul of a devil
when he creates a new devil fruit so the
power of the artificial devil fruit will
never be equal to the power of a genuine
devil fruit this theory that an entire
race of devils used to exist in the one
piece world that each of them had
supernatural powers and that they were
all sealed inside of devil fruits is a
pretty wild one man it's certainly not
the most likely theory let's be real but
if true it would definitely change
everything we thought we knew about the
world of one piece and it's history
what if sun got nika created the devil
fruits in chapter 1044 the goddess
mentioned how nika is only limited by
his own creativity in many ways nika is
a sun god of creation so going off at
this i've gone down the rabbit hole of
considering what if the sunlight eve
tree or even devil fruits were created
by sangha nika in the past i really
first thought of this idea when you look
at the similarities between the sun god
of creation raw of egyptian mythology
and luffy who was also now a sun god of
creation and with this new gear 5 power
luffy is finally able to do the things
that he's only ever dreamed of when nika
the possibilities are truly endless and
i'm sure that this is only the beginning
of nika's full potential since we still
have a few big arcs to go in the story
so going off of what and meg mentioned
earlier maybe a human named nika ate the
first devil fruit from a tree and this
gave him the powers of a god the power
to create anything he could imagine and
if we're going so far back in time the
world may have been less advanced and so
the imagination and creativity would
really be important to create these
powers the implication of this would be
that maybe luffy in the future could
possibly be able to create a new set of
devil fruits and something this
ridiculous fits right there with why the
golden state fear this power's very
existence going so far to erase it from
history another possibility could be
what if the devil fruits were created by
the d clan or more specifically the
ancient kingdom we know that there was
ancient technology in the past one
example of this are the ancient weapons
now what if on a much smaller scale the
ancient kingdom had an army of devil
fruit users and after meeting toki we
now know that devil fruits existed at
least 800 years ago during the voice
entry era in one piece people like nico
robbie and goldie roger are deemed
devils by the government and in robin's
case she researches the ancient kingdom
the ancient weapons and the true history
finding the pony glyphs roger was
similar but he was also the freest man
who directly opposed the government by
becoming the pirate king is it possible
that the world government or the
celestial dragons called the fruits
devil fruits because they came from
their previous enemies of the d-clan or
the advanced technology of the ancient
kingdom dr vegapunk is someone who is
tied deeply to devil for research he has
created unexplainable experiments like
funk freed he's replicated momonosuke's
devil fruit almost perfectly and he was
able to incorporate kizaru's light laser
beam into the pacifistas but what's most
interesting to me is how the mad science
group was once the top of all signs were
members like judge queen caesar and of
course vegapunk this group was shut down
for researching and conducting illegal
activities but eventually vegapunk would
end up working for the world government
and we know exactly what illegal
research means in one piece the world's
biggest taboos the pony clips and now
this science group could they all be
connected in some way but the funding
and the resources provided to vegapunk
after joining the government is
interesting to me that they allowed them
to continue these experiments as long as
they are for the world government and i
bring all of this up to say that just
like the elites at the top are
interested in the ancient weapons for
their own power like we saw in enos
lobby the government might have been
opposed to devil fruits but made
exceptions if the power was harnessed
for their own control vegapunk is known
to be centuries ahead of his time so if
there fruits did come from the ancient
kingdom his fascination with these
fruits could be all the more valuable
with see prism stone being tied to wano
i wonder if the reason why this nation
was so valuable in the past was because
they controlled the biggest weakness of
the d-clan or the ancient kingdom's
fruit weapons and finally the biggest
reason for me believing that devil
fruits may have been created by the
ancient kingdom besides the devil
labeling is due to the fact that it
seems like almost no information or
history is left of them there's overall
a very limited knowledge of them so i
think it's more than a fair question to
ask if these devil fruits are connected
to the ancient kingdom the d clan and
the void century we know that the
ancient kingdom was erased from history
so maybe along with the extinguished
light went the truth about devil fruits
and their origins
and now for my personal favorite theory
about the secret origins of the devil
fruits the theory that they came from
the moon or rather that they were
created by the advanced ancient
civilization that used to live on the
moon now i came up with this theory
during my own research but i'm sure that
i'm not the first one to ever talk about
it i just personally haven't seen it
discussed anywhere else it all starts
with an l's epic cover story that
features his journey to the moon the
cover page for chapter 470 features nl
and the four automata from earth
studying a mural or wall painting made
by the ancient winged people who used to
live on the moon in the upper right
corner of the image we see two moon
people working on one of the moon
automata and these moon automata look
almost exactly like the four earth
automata except for their outfits and
wings i will talk more about this
similarity a little bit later but if you
look just above the two people who are
working on this particular automaton you
will see a sphere with a swirly design
inside of it although this sphere may
just represent like a light or something
i couldn't help but think that this
swirly design looks a lot like the
swirly designs that are featured on so
many known devil fruits we also now know
that devil fruits have a will of their
own and clearly the automata that the
moon civilization created have their own
will as well so if this moon
civilization was able to imprint a form
of sentience into these inanimate
objects the automata then it isn't too
hard to believe that they may have also
been able to imprint a form of sentience
into the devil fruits themselves we know
that the moon people eventually flew
down to earth because they ran out of
resources on the moon we know they
stopped on the sky islands and
presumably they arrived there first
because that is closer to the moon than
the actual ground some members of the
moon civilization seemingly remained on
the sky islands and the skypeans are
their descendants the moon people also
made it down to the surface and they
created the ancient city of shandora at
least one 1
100 years ago we can also surmise that
some of the moon people made it to
karakuri island the birthplace of dr
vegapunk that is because in the modern
day a resident of karakuri island named
dr tsukimi was able to build four
automata that are remarkably similar to
the automata on the moon and not just in
terms of the technology used to create
them but even in terms of their basic
appearance the karakuri automata wear
different outfits but otherwise they
look and function just like the moon
automata and the similarities are simply
too blatant to be considered a
coincidence i believe that the residents
of karakuri island were directly exposed
to the advanced technology of the moon
civilization
probably because some of the members of
this civilization settled on karakuri
and that is why this island is home to
such incredible and futuristic
technology in the first place but the
automata are only the beginning
vegapunk is well known for his research
on devil fruits the seastone and the
lineage factor and his knowledge of
these important subjects is said to be
500 years ahead of current technology in
the world of one piece or rather the
current technology on earth vegapunk's
breakthroughs in devil fruit research
could actually be a direct result of the
moon civilization's presence on karakuri
island if i am correct that some moon
people visited karakuri or even settled
there and if the moon people really are
the ones who created the devil fruits in
the first place then this would not only
explain why karakuri island is so
technologically advanced it would also
explain why vegapunk's research on devil
fruits is so far ahead of its time it is
because vegapunk gained special insight
into the truth about devil fruits from
the very people who created them there
also appears to be an ancient connection
between the moon civilization and wano
which is significant because wano is
where the rare mineral known as sea
stone originates sea stone is a
substance that can drain a devil fruit
user's stamina and nullify their powers
when the devil fruit user comes into
direct contact with it so sea stone is
definitely an important aspect of the
wider devil fruit story we know that
seastone originates on wano and we know
that the kozuki clan from wano are the
creators of the ponoglyphs but did you
know that the cover page for chapter 472
a page which shows nl looking at the
wall murals on the moon also features
what looks a lot like ponoglyphs in the
upper right corner of the mural if you
compare this writing to the writing on
the poneglyphs you will notice many
similar elements including the little
dots the little triangles the little
symbols that look like upside down and
sideways l's and so on since this
writing on the moon dates back several
centuries before the void century it is
possible that this moon language was
actually the basis of the language used
to create the poneglyphs which if true
would connect the moon civilization
directly to wano the people from the
moon must have visited wano and the
kozuki clan's knowledge of the
ponoglyphs may have been the direct
result of their visit on top of that the
cover page for chapter 448 shows dr
tsukimi working on one of the automata
and if you look closely two katana are
seen hanging on the wall in the top left
corner if these are swords that
originate in wano itself then this
suggests a potential connection between
karakuri island and wano since wano has
been strictly closed off from the
outside world for many years getting a
katana from wano or gaining the
knowledge to produce a faithful replica
would not be easy without a direct
connection to wano itself now there are
katana in one piece in places other than
wano so this isn't conclusive proof but
it is a possibility it's clear to me
that the moon civilization will turn out
to be extremely important in the final
saga of the one piece story and i think
that the moon people will end up playing
a crucial role in the secret history of
the world i think it's possible that
this highly advanced civilization
actually invented the devil fruits and
this very power may be what allowed them
to move from the moon to the earth and
establish a great kingdom there but this
power may also have been the reason for
their downfall since by its very nature
devil fruit power is one that can easily
fall into the wrong hands the enemies of
the moon people which would probably be
rival kingdoms that originated on earth
may have stolen their devil fruits and
used them to destroy the ancient kingdom
and to erase it from history leaving
only a few scattered remnants behind
such as the residents of the sky islands
the technology on karakuri the
ponoglyphs and of course the devil
fruits themselves all will be revealed
when vegapunk finally shows up and if by
some chance it turns out that he has
wings on his back i will laugh harder
than roger laughed on laugh tale
let me know what your favorite devil
fruit origin theory is down in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video do me a quick favor and please
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for more one piece content thanks again
to marshall d preach for helping me out
definitely check out his channel link in
the description if you're looking for a
video to watch next check out my theory
that luffy has lunarian dna link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys